this is the time it's time to pull the
sheet i don't know if we've got some big
reveal graphically planned but go ahead
tell us who number 40 is well number 40
i'm going to go with tyrod taylor there
ty rod taylor's my number 40 quarterback
in football and you know a guy that of
course we all know has started played
you know considerable uh games minutes
seasons you know for the bills uh of
course the browns last year got a little
unlucky with this starts last year
had some times with the baltimore ravens
but to me ty rod taylor is like the
perfect backup in the nfl if you're your
starter you're always going to want more
and
what people wonder what i what what what
makes ty rod taylor the number 40th
quarterback in all the football and all
that you know i think first of all he's
athletic i get that but what holds him
back i know people ask me sometimes and
i do think it's more of a he's a little
bit of a game manager mike i think
that's one thing that is you know uh
bothered me about tyrod taylor and we
saw that as soon as baker mayfield got
in the game last year with the cleveland
browns all of a sudden the ball started
aggressively being pushed down the field
ty rod taylor is one of those guys who
yeah not going to turn over the ball
he's going to a good completion
percentage but he's going to leave some
yards and plays that are there to be had
down the middle of the field at times
because he's too conservative in nature
and too
consumed with managing the football game
in general
three years as the full-time starter for
the buffalo bills before being traded to
cleveland and really when when the most
memorable thing from his tenure with the
browns is the question of whether or not
his first name is tyrod or terrod if
that's the first thing you think of when
you think of his time with the browns
his time with the browns was not very
memorable and and really you could argue
that his performances early in the
season
made it even more clear that baker
mayfield should have been the week one
starter making the decision to put
taylor in front of mayfield even more
questionable after the fact but you know
here's the thing he's not a starter he's
a backup for phillip rivers in la now
is he good enough you say he's a game
manager is he good enough that he could
come in in the event that rivers ever
would get injured and miss a game or two
could he come in and win a game for you
if you could have the opportunity to get
him ready spent the whole week coming up
with the game plan that works for tyrod
taylor get him out there on the field
and trust him to get a victory yes you
you definitely can there's no doubt
about it that's the thing you like now
you are you going to be able to put them
in the game and go hey let's have the
same free freewheeling offense that
we've had you know with philip rivers
we're going to let the guy control the
field and he'll make the right decisions
throwing the football all that no
there's going to have to be a different
plan of attack will you still be able to
be effective in the drop back pass game
yes but you know with a guy like ty rod
taylor the chargers yeah you're gonna
rely on the run game you know add
bootlegs and play actions things like
that maybe that you wouldn't do with
phillip rivers that fit tyrod taylor's
skill set a little bit better so uh from
that standpoint you know yes certainly
can come in do things but you know it's
just not gonna be a high-flying affair
like you would see with phillip rivers
throwing the ball to some of the weapons
they got on the chargers
you know i think back to 2015 when he
became a free agent the broncos really
wanted him gary kubiak was the head
coach at the time kubiak had worked with
taylor in baltimore when he was the
backup to joe flacco and taylor said i'm
not interested because they had peyton
manning and brock osweiler at the top of
the depth chart in 2015. that's when he
chose the bills went on to be that
three-year starter right bills trade him
to the browns and then he was kind of
the forgotten man in free agency and and
i felt bad for him because it was an
injury that ended his his run as the
browns starting quarterback and baker
mayfield came in and played so well
there was no going back to taylor at
that point but you never know what he
may have cooked up down the road as
quarterbacks go and we're seeing guys
playing deeper and deeper into their 30s
he's not even 30 yet
and hey if nothing else he's a guy that
that the chargers can evaluate for the
possibility of being a bridge
quarterback to the young guy that they
may get whenever rivers retires and i
mention the possibility of replacing
rivers if he's injured he's never missed
a game during his time as starter with
the charger so you know i think the big
move for the chargers here is
evaluate taylor could he be a guy that
becomes that two or three year answer
while you keep looking for the next
long-term franchise quarterback if and
when philip rivers ever walks away and
then 40 there's nothing there hey
there's no shame in being number 40 if
you're not a starter yeah right you're
not number one on the depth chart of
your team it at least shows he's in the
top 25 of all backups yeah no definitely
is i mean he's one of those guys like
we'll see that in front of them that are
fringe you know back end starters if
they were on the right team in the nfl
uh and if not yes the rest of these guys
are really really quality backups that
you can trust your football team
when these guys are under center
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports